ein bisschen schminken
ihr macht das alle freiwillig ne
gut dass ich hinter der Kamera stehe
auch die Kamera fahren
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es eine halloweentorte ihr
habt sie euch gewünscht ihr habt gesagt
ja wir wollen Halloween hier habt ihr
Halloween abgesehen davon dass ich
dieses Make-up auch in einem Video Zeige
und die Haare habe ich heute diese Torte
zubereitet ein 3d-kürbis mit einer
Überraschung im Innern es gab ein paar
Herausforderungen beim Backen aber
ansonsten finde ich ist der Kürbis eine
Torte die man schon ganz cool
hinbekommen kann also ich finde die
Torte einfach genial und ich habe noch
zwei Überraschungen für euch die
schleichen sich gerade hier am Boden
entlang und
hi ihr zwei
[Musik]
zur Krönung der mini-kürbis den hat Ella
ganz alleine gemacht tatsächlich und ja
die
kleine und dieses Make-up hat sie mir
gemacht also richtig cool ich muss echt
sagen ihr beide ihr seid einfach
wahnsinnig talentiert Hammer ganz
alleine geschminkt ganz alleine
zubereitet was soll ich da noch sagen
diese Torte habe ich mir auf drei Tage
aufgeteilt einfach dass es nicht so
stressig ist das heißt wenn Ihr auch
eine Halloween Torte macht und ihr habt
nicht so viel Zeit weil ihr vielleicht
auch arbeitet dann könnt ihr das ganz
gerne auch noch Feierabend immer mal
wieder was machen zum Beispiel Tag 1 die
Böden backen die Füllung zubereiten und
dann am zweiten Tag die Torte füllen am
dritten Tag fertig dekorieren dann habt
das richtig cool oder ihr macht dann
einem Stück wobei bei so einer Torte
immer Wartezeit gut ist denn sie muss ja
schön gekühlt sein also legen wir jetzt
direkt los mit der Torte denn wir wollen
sie auch gleich angeschnitten sehen ja
und vor allem probieren
du darfst kein Blut trinken
elato ist genug kappt heute das reicht
jetzt mal
okay noch einen Schluck trinken
die Kinder irgendwann Trauma gut
ich hatte mal Karl den Kürbis gemacht
der war schon ziemlich cool jetzt möchte
ich aber einen gruseligen weißen Kürbis
machen
[Musik]
jetzt packe ich erstmal den Kuchen
jetzt geht es darum Geschmack in die
Torte zu bekommen und ich habe gestern
bereits meine Tortenböden vorbereitet
das ist auch immer ganz gut wenn ihr
plant eine Motivtorte zu gestalten backt
am besten am Tag zu fort die Böden damit
die schön abkühlen können und dann
könnte sie nämlich in den Kühlschrank
stellen damit sie schön stabil und fest
sind ich habe dafür einfach meine Mandel
Rührteig gemacht und da ist richtig
schön saftig dafür nehmt ihr nämlich
einfach die Eier verrührt sie mit Zucker
Salz und Vanilleextrakt richtig schön
cremig anschließend gebt ihr hier am
besten noch direkt die Lebensmittelfarbe
dazu und weil ich möchte dass der Kürbis
innen eben orange ist gebe ich da eine
orangene Lebensmittelfarbe dazu lasst
die kurz einrühren und nehme aber auch
nur so viel dass die Farbe okay ist denn
durchs backen wir die Farbe verstärkt
also wenn Lebensmittelfarbe erhitzt wird
dann wird sie verstärkt und die wird
dann richtig schön grell danach kommen
einfach nur noch die zwei Flüssigkeiten
dazu nämlich Buttermilch und Öl die
werden ganz kurz eingerührt und
abschließend dann mehl Backpulver und
Mandeln wobei ich hier jetzt mein
backmehl verwendet habe weil Backpulver
einfach schon mit dabei ist das wird
dann nur noch kurz eingerührt bis eine
schöne homogene perfekte Masse entsteht
und wenn der Teig fertig ist kommen wir
dann in die drei vorbereiteten
springformböden ich habe jetzt hier die
springformböden verwendet weil doch der
Teig relativ flüssig ist deswegen
einfach drei Formen weil ich dann die
Teige gleichmäßig einfüllen kann sie
haben eine kürzere Backzeit Backen
gleichmäßig und sind dann perfekt und so
habe ich sie dann über Nacht abkühlen
lassen habe Sie anschließend einfach nur
mit einem tortenretter abgedeckt und da
sind sie jetzt eben immer noch drin also
perfekt die Tortenböden sind bereit
jetzt geht es darum Geschmack in die
Torte zu bekommen
[Musik]
zu laut sonst kommt der Murat her und
macht einen Raumduft oder ein Parfüm mit
Quitten
danke
und ich habe mir jetzt gerade noch
gedacht ich mache glaube ich einfach
eine Marmelade ich habe nämlich draußen
im Garten habe ich Quitten die kennt ihr
vielleicht vielleicht hat jemand von
euch Gewittern die gibt's aber auch im
Supermarkt und beim Bauern um die Ecke
Quitten das ist so eine komische so ein
komisches Steinobst was so verzehrbar
also es ist verzehrbar aber es schmeckt
nicht gut die meisten Kochen daher Gelee
draus oder eben Kompott Marmelade und
ich muss aber dazu sagen dass die
türkische Quitte auf türkisch heißt die
eiwa die kann man tatsächlich so
verzehren weil sie echt schmeckt wie so
ein Mix aus Apfel und
Birne aber nicht so süß und mein Papa
hat immer früher für uns geschält und
der Papa erzählt es auch bis heute die
Quitten haben wir so eine komische
mehlige fällige Oberfläche und wenn man
die dann so ein bisschen reibt und dran
riecht dann riechen Quitten echt extrem
gut und immer wenn er von Quitten
erzählt dann muss eigentlich immer
weinen weil er sagt seine Mama die hat
früher wenn Sie die Wäsche gewaschen hat
und die hatten ja jetzt eben nicht so
Waschmittel wie wir heute was eben mega
gut nicht und da muss man einfach gucken
dass die Wäsche sauber ist und dann hat
sie immer Quitten mit so Wäsche gelegt
damit die Wäsche gut riecht und dann
weint er immer weil das ihn an seine
Mama erinnert und ich weine dann immer
mit weil ich es mega süß finde und ich
meine Oma nicht kennengelernt habe
ja deswegen hier habe ich jetzt die
Quitten aus dem Garten die habe ich
gerade vorhin geerntet habe sie schon
schön abgewaschen jetzt ist die
Oberfläche schön glatt und die riechen
einfach extrem gut Anna kommt du musst
jetzt mal an der Kette riechen du darfst
an der Quitte riechen die riecht so gut
und das weiß ich nur weil mein Papa das
gesagt hat
aber so gut gell aber man kann sich
definieren man kann es nicht definieren
es riecht einfach gut
Quitte riecht einfach gut ja und ich
habe mir gedacht weil gerade Saison ist
nämlich Quitten nehmen ein Hokkaido
Kürbis und Gelierzucker ich habe jetzt
hier den 2:1 Gelierzucker weil ich bin
ja eigentlich Fan von 3:1 verliert sogar
damit nicht so süß ist aber hier habe
ich ja den Vorteil das Kürbis und die
Quitte auch nicht so süß sind deswegen
passt der 2:1 Zucker das heißt ein
ganzes Päckchen Gelierzucker dann das
sind 500 Gramm und dann brauche ich eben
500 Gramm Kürbis 500 g Quitten ich nehme
noch Vanilleextrakt und dann Saft einer
Zitrone und was ihr wissen müsst bei
Quitten dass sie ja schon relativ hart
sind
wobei bei denen hier geht's tatsächlich
wie gesagt ist so eine türkische Quitte
die wir gepflanzt haben und bei den
anderen Quitten müsste halt schon gut
aufpassen auf die Finger also wie auch
bei Kürbis einfach aufpassen beim
Schneiden und ich werde jetzt hier das
Kerngehäuse rausnehmen und beides
würfeln
und dann miteinander verrühren und ihr
könnt das jetzt entweder mit dem Messer
würfeln oder ihr nimmt den Würfel
Aufsatz wenn ihr einen habt für die
Kenwood zum Beispiel
und was an der Quitte noch so besonders
ist gerade wenn man sie roh verzerrt die
lindert Bauchschmerzen Halsschmerzen
enthält mega viel Vitamin C und es ist
wirklich so ein Steinobst was einfach
sehr gesund ist und ich würde jetzt
einfach mal der Anna also nicht weil du
irgendwie Verdauungsprobleme hast aber
einfach zum probieren weil du vorhin
gesagt hast du kennst keine Quitten ich
lass dich jetzt Quitten probieren
die sind also vielleicht als Vorwarnung
die machen den Mund so ein bisschen
mehlig aber die türkische Quitte ist
echt die kann man roh verzehren ich
glaube die türkische kenne ich
ja
man sagt dem türkischen auch so
[Musik]
ur also der Mund wird so der zieht sich
so zusammen
aber schmeckt gut voll lecker
[Musik]
ja und die werde ich jetzt hier
entkernen und dann eben schön würfeln
und die Schale enthält übrigens auch
Pektin also tatsächlich kann man
Quittengelee oder Marmelade auch ohne
Gelierzucker herstellen aber ich mische
das jetzt auch mit dem Kürbis deswegen
nehme ich Gelierzucker muss ich auch
nicht so lange kochen aber ansonsten
geht es tatsächlich sogar auch ohne weil
Pektin eben auch so ein Bindemittel ist
was auf den Gelierzucker enthalten ist
[Musik]
also die Twitter ging leicht der Kürbis
ist naja
ja dann nehme ich jetzt auch noch
Hokkaido weil ich da die Schale nicht
abschälen muss und dann habe ich eine
richtig schöne tolle Farbe später
[Musik]
hier zeige ich euch jetzt mal den Würfel
damit muss ich sagen habe auch schon 20
Liter Kartoffelsuppe gemacht für ein
Kindergeburtstag dann nehme ich immer
perfekt weil man dann doch nicht so viel
selber schneiden muss
und dann
kommt nämlich alles da oben rein kommt
gewürfelt raus
[Musik]
und ich muss sagen Grad Kürbis und
Quitte die sind halt schon sehr hart ne
aber der Schaft ist und einfach nicht so
fest drücken die Maschine die holt sich
das Obst und Gemüse von alleine
ich helfe dann nur ein bisschen mit und
schiebe einfach nur ein bisschen nach
[Musik]
und da gibt es dann so ein Vorsatz und
dann nehmt ihr das aber am besten runter
damit ihr nicht an der Maschine drückt
und dann könnt ihr nämlich hier so zack
das geht jetzt ein bisschen schwer weil
es quitten sind
aber
mit Kartoffeln und so weiter geht's
natürlich einfach
so da ist das hier nämlich
nehmen wir den letzten Rest noch mit
rein und jetzt am besten direkt
Zitronensaft drauf damit die Quitten
nicht braun werden denn ich möchte dass
meine Marmelade eine schöne Farbe hat
und nicht oxidiert und braun wird
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt hier der Zucker dazu
und dann kann ich das ganze jetzt auch
hier in der kenwatch tatsächlich kochen
ihr könnt aber auch die Marmelade
natürlich einfach im Kochtopf Kochen auf
der Packungsanleitung der gelier das
geliert sogar steht hier auch die Angabe
meistens aufkochen vier Minuten sprudeln
kochen ihr könnt auch gerne hier noch
bei Bedarf etwas Wasser dazugeben denn
der Kürbis und die Quitten die sind
schon so ein bisschen schon so ein
bisschen trockener und normalerweise
wartet mal auch ein bisschen bis der
Zucker so ein bisschen die Flüssigkeit
zieht aber ich koche das jetzt hier in
der Kenwood da gibt's sogar ein Programm
das nennt sich Obst Kompott weil der
Kürbis und die Quitte die sind ja schon
recht hart und da reichen die vier
Minuten Kochzeit definitiv nicht
deswegen lasse ich dir jetzt hier 20
Minuten kochen und ich gebe noch Wasser
dazu
und das was ihr jetzt hier seht ist die
einfache Menge also 500 Gramm Kürbis 500
Gramm Quitte 500 Gramm Gelierzucker 2:1
und das koche ich jetzt hier erstmal und
aus dem Rest mache ich später dann noch
was und dann kann ich in der
Zwischenzeit schon mal mein pumpkin
Spice Gewürz machen
[Musik]
es riecht so gut hier oh es riecht so
gut ich bin ganz froh dass ich noch
Zutaten habe ich mache später noch mal
die Menge hier habe ich jetzt eine
gewürzzusammenstellung für euch und zwar
ist es dieses pumpkin Spice Gewürz in
Amerika ist es echt sehr bekannt weil
damit so gefühlt alles gemacht wird zur
Herbstzeit wir haben hier Zimt Ingwer
geriebene Muskatnuss Nelken und Piment
und diese Zutaten verrühre ich jetzt
einfach die kommen hier in ein Glas und
das ist dann so eine Gewürzmischung
damit könnt ihr Waffeln verfeinern
Cremes Kompott also könnte theoretisch
auch dieses Kompott die Marmelade damit
machen es schmeckt gut es riecht gut ihr
könnt Getränke zubereiten wenn ihr
möchtet mache ich euch dann natürlich
gerne einen reallo dann short dazu
mit Rezeptideen
[Musik]
also ich stelle mir schon manchmal so
der Murat im kürbiskostüm vor wie so ein
Hokkaido oh lecker das riecht echt gut
okay die Marmelade ist gleich soweit ich
werde jetzt schon mal meine
Einmachgläser sterilisieren im Backofen
bei dampfstufe 100 Grad 15 Minuten
perfekt ansonsten kocht ihr sie einfach
aus
also hier oben kommt bei mir der
Wassertank rein
es gibt mittlerweile aber auch die
Backöfen mit Festwasseranschluss den
kriege ich auch bald
mit noch ausgetauscht und dann könnt ihr
die Gläser hier auf so ein Lochblech
stellen es gibt aber auch das Blech vom
Bosch Backofen das so ein dampfgarblech
das könnt ihr auch benutzen mit der
Öffnung nach unten die Deckel auch mit
rein denn auch die Deckel müssen
sterilisiert werden
und dann 15 Minuten bei 100 Grad
und die Zeit läuft auch erst ab dann
wenn der Ofen die 100 Grad erreicht hat
deswegen passt es perfekt und wenn ihr
die Sallys Welt App habt dann könnt ihr
sogar direkt aus der App heraus die
Einstellungen an den Backofen senden da
müsste das nicht mehr selber einstellen
das macht dann die Äpfel für euch
[Musik]
jetzt sind die Gläser fertig beim Öffnen
des Backofens und Dampfgarers immer
aufpassen dass ihr nicht den Dampf ins
Gesicht bekommt ist nämlich sehr sehr
heiß und das tolle ist also der Punkt
gerade ab das tolle ist wenn ihr auch
mal einen Backofen habt der so ein
bisschen eingebrannt ist mit
Lebensmittelresten und so weiter wenn
ihr danach was dämpft dann löst sich der
ganze Schmutz von alleine und wenn ihr
möchtet dann könnt ihr die Marmelade
auch gerne mit dem pumpkin Spice Gewürz
noch verfeinern muss aber nicht sein
aber wenn ihr wollt dass sie hinten
winterlich herbstlich schmeckt dann
passt perfekt ich lasse die jetzt
allerdings so denn das pumpt ganz weiß
Gewürz kommt bei mir in die Buttercreme
die Marmelade die sieht so gut aus die
wird so ein bisschen
moosartig weil der Kürbis und die Quitte
einfach so eine musige Konsistenz haben
also lecker
[Musik]
lecker
ich habe bestimmt voll viel Geld für
Kürbisse ausgegeben dabei ist der Gürtel
der Garten voll mit Kürbis aber ich habe
gerade der Bauer soll er auch was
verdienen deswegen den haben wir hier
von regionalen Bauern die ganze Kürbis
Deko
jetzt bereite ich die Buttercreme vor
dafür mache ich die Swiss mir rank
Buttercreme also eine Buttercreme mit
Eiweiß es gibt ja auch die italienische
Buttercreme die ist auch von dann
tauglich die ist auch sehr lecker es
gibt auch noch eine französische der
Unterschied ist einfach folgender bei
der französischen Buttercreme wird ein
ganzes Ei verwendet also Eiweiß und
Eigelb diese auch so ein bisschen
cremiger ich muss auch sagen
geschmacklich sehr gut aber wenn man die
zum Beispiel einfärben will muss man
halt bedenken dass da immer dieser
Gelbstich vom Eigelb mit drin ist die
italienische und die Schweizer
Buttercreme die sind eigentlich was die
Konsistenz angeht identisch nur der Zug
nur die Zubereitung ist eben anders das
heißt bei der italienischen das Eiweiß
muss ja pasteurisiert werden damit
Salmonellengefahr und so weiter nicht
besteht und die Creme eben auch tagelang
haltbar ist bei der italienischen ist es
so da wird ein Zuckersirup gekocht und
damit wird das Eiweiß sozusagen
sterilisiert und bei der Schweizer
Buttercreme wird einfach eiweiß mit
Zucker eben verrührt und erhitzt und das
ganze wird so eben
sterilisiert pasteurisiert und ich muss
sagen mittlerweile mache ich
italienische Buttercreme eigentlich
nicht mehr weil ich es mit Zuckersirup
einfach zu kompliziert finde und ich
mache es dann einfach eben entweder im
Topf herkömmlich über dem heißen
Wasserbad einfach kochen lassen oder mit
der Kenwood und weil ich jetzt noch viel
vor mir habe immer es natürlich mit der
Kenwood da mache ich mir die Arbeit ein
bisschen leichter ich zeige euch aber
erstmal kurz die Zutaten für die
Buttercreme verwende ich 180 Gramm
Eiweiß 325 Gramm Zucker etwas Salz mein
pumpkin Spice Gewürz Vanilleextrakt 540
Gramm Butter die ist bereits weich auf
Raumtemperatur und 130 Gramm Puderzucker
und jetzt gebt ihr hier das Eiweiß in
die Rührschüssel Zucker Salz Vanille
dazu und dann muss es wie gesagt 10
Minuten lang etwa bei 70 Grad erhitzt
werden so sagt man
tötet man wirklich auch alles ab was
Keime und Bakterien haben könnte falls
ihr das über dem kochenden Wasserbad
macht wirklich Wasser aufsetzen eine
Schüssel drüber Eiweiß und Zucker rein
und ständig rühren zehn Minuten lang
über dem kochenden Wasser ich habe hier
aber auch Suchmaschine einfach so ein
Programm es ist nämlich so die Maschine
zählt die Zeit erst dann runter wenn es
Eiweiß wirklich heiß ist das heißt ich
kann eigentlich muss ich keine zehn
Minuten einstellen das reichen auch vier
bis fünf Minuten weil eben dann erst die
Zeit gezählt wird
könnt ihr hier zum Beispiel auf
Programme gehen
auf Schweizer Baiser italienisch Baiser
was auch immer ich würde jetzt hier
Schweizer Baiser nehmen
dann steht hier 10 Minuten 40 Grad 40
Grad reichen mir tatsächlich nicht ich
nehme 70 Grad
und
maximum nehme ich auch runter ich mache
jetzt mal auf Stufe 5 und das kann ich
ein bisschen reduzieren
ich mache mal sechs Minuten und jetzt
sieht man da drin ganz schön dass der
Zucker sich auch auflöst die Eiweißmasse
wird jetzt am Volumen gewinnen und nach
diesem 6 Minuten richtig heiß erhitzen
muss ich die Creme dann noch kalt rühren
jetzt könnt ihr hier einfach noch mal
weiterrühren aber ohne Temperatur also
jetzt von der Hitze runter nehmen bis
die Masse abgekühlt ist
[Musik]
jetzt die baiser-masse schön kalt
gerührt so sieht sie aus die nehme ich
jetzt hier kurz zur Seite die darf jetzt
hier stehen bleiben und dann kann ich in
der Zwischenzeit die Butter mit dem
Puderzucker mit dem pumpkin Spice Gewürz
und Vanilleextrakt weiß cremig rühren
das ist immer ganz wichtig damit die
Buttercreme nicht so butterig schmeckt
sondern luftig leicht und locker wird
und wichtig ist auch auch wenn ihr auf
dem Herd zum Beispiel die Eiweißmasse
zubereitet die muss jetzt wirklich kalt
gerührt sein denn wenn die noch zu warm
ist dann schmilzt die Butter und dann
habt ihr eine Soße statt eine
Buttercreme und das wollen wir ja nicht
[Musik]
perfekt
jetzt ist die Butter weiß cremig die
Eiweißmasse kalt und jetzt mache ich so
dass ich die Baisermasse hier rein gebe
und die Butter langsam einrühren also
immer so schrittweise und dann schön
cremig rühren
[Musik]
die gute Buttercreme
meine Fläche sauber die meisten geputzte
küchenfläche glaube ich Deutschland
weltweit die habe ich jetzt einfach
wieder rein gegeben ich hoffe es ist
okay für dich
[Musik]
oh mein Gott look at this beautiful
Buttercreme
wow
das ist ein pumpkin Spice buttercream
ich muss ja allein schon
also jetzt mal so selbstlos wie immer
bin müssen wir einfach mal verkosten ob
die Buttercreme gut schmeckt um zu
wissen ob pumpkin Spice Gewürz enough
ist oder ob noch was dazu muss das heißt
wir müssen die verkosten die Buttercreme
Maja so oder so
bevor es die Zuschauer nachmachen und es
ist ja bevor dann ein Zuschauer die
Torte nach Macht und so sagt Sally da
hätte noch Gewürz dran können hier ist
übrigens jetzt völlig okay das am Rand
entlang zu schlagen denn die ist echt
stabil
das heißt einmal kurz gucken
also
wenn eure Buttercreme
diese Konsistenz haben ist sie perfekt
ich denke dann immer schon in so Shorts
und reels weil ich finde das so
Buttercreme so ein eigenes short Wert
ist eigentlich weil
Buttercreme einfach so schön ist und so
smooth
und so elegant
ja irgendwann wird man es einfach so wir
machen ein Buttercreme Tag Anna
ja okay der 11.12 ist ab sofort der Tag
der internationaler Tag der Buttercreme
ich glaube für Anna weiß das größte
Geschenk wenn ich dann sagen wird okay
ich mache jetzt alle Sorten Buttercreme
die ich kenne
zu Buttercreme vergessen
Buttercreme verkosten oh mein Gott
Buttercreme Video ich mach mal ganz im
Ernst also einfach so welche Arten von
Buttercreme gibt die Swiss die
italienische die deutsche die
amerikanische also
ich sage ja nur Idee ist Idee
durch die mal an bitte
okay
den Blick sehen
und Anna singt dann dazu
oh mein Gott
und jetzt ist es pumpkin Spice Gewürz
sehr zurückhaltend sehr aromatisch aber
ich gebe noch ein Esslöffel dazu denn
ich will schon dass es basic schmeckt
was sagst du das weißt du ja
darf ich kurz Filmen wie du aus doch
kann man das bitte kurz als
einblenden ja
Löffel abnehmen ja okay ich muss mir
aber erstmal meine Buttercreme kümmern
oh das schmeckt wow
wow
ich bin selber immer begeistert wie gut
die Creme schmeckt
[Musik]
dann habe ich jetzt alle Komponenten
fertig das heißt Kuchen Buttercreme
Marmelade
hier
kann ich die Kuchenböden erstmal
rauslösen und halbieren
[Musik]
jetzt wird die Torte gefüllt dafür nehme
ich jetzt anders als sonst einen runden
Boden für unten lasst euch nicht davon
abbringen dass mein Papa hier ist der
hat die Katze mit uns vermisst deswegen
alles gut ich kann einfach so oft sagen
wir drehen aber egal
mein Papa der ist so süß
ach ja
jetzt bestreicht ihr den Boden ich weiß
dann immer nie wie ich aus so
Situationen wieder zurückkommt zum
Rezept ich beschreibe ich den Boden mit
meiner Kürbis Quittenmarmelade
für dich die Quitten mit meinem Papa
sorgfältig ausgesucht habe im Garten
Halloween auch noch so ein Ding da kam
ein Papa so gar nichts damit anfangen ne
na ja
hier die Quittenmarmelade dann
Buttercreme drauf und so fühle ich jetzt
die gesamte Torte und weil es dann
Kürbis wird möchte ich natürlich auch
dass der jetzt von unten und oben her
schon mal ein bisschen rund ist deswegen
die geraden Böden innen rein und oben
drauf auch noch mal einen runterboden
also da darf die Torte jetzt wirklich
schöne Rundungen bekommen ich wollte ja
ursprünglich geschmacklich noch Oreos
mit reinbringen aber ich muss sagen dass
die Creme und die Marmelade
geschmacklich schon so der Hammer sind
die mache ich jetzt nicht kaputt mit
Oreos muss ich dir ganz ehrlich sagen
oder was sagt ihr Okay wie wäre es wenn
man asmr machen einfach nur Torten für
dann sagt man einer Torten backen ist
stressig das ist doch nicht stressig ist
doch schön
man entspannt dabei
[Musik]
ich bin mir einfach einen der riecht
nach Kürbis dabei richte halt nicht nach
Kürbis
[Musik]
jetzt der letzte Boden
dann muss die Torte erstmal in den
Kühlschrank denn also ich drücke das
jetzt auch tatsächlich absichtlich hier
am Rande etwas nach unten die Torte soll
nämlich rund werden wie ein Kürbis und
ich nehme jetzt noch ein bisschen
Buttercreme um hier am Rand so ein
bisschen was aufzufüllen aber die Torte
wird jetzt eingepackt ich nehme da
einfach so ein bisschen tortenrandfolie
Tortenring drum Deckel drauf und dann
muss die tatsächlich für mindestens zwei
Stunden in den Kühlschrank damit sie
schön fest wird die Buttercreme schön
fest wird denn die Torte muss ja gleich
zugeschnitten werden das heißt in der
Zeit kann ich aufräumen
noch ein bisschen Buttercreme herstellen
denn ich habe es jetzt schon ordentlich
und üppig gefüllt und ich meine
Buttercreme hier im Hause wird immer
verzerrt ähm das heißt wir können später
auch im Löffel das ja draus machen für
immer
und es bleibt noch vielleicht ein
bisschen Zeit für gruselige Halloween
Gesichter
so als alle ein bisschen schminken
[Musik]
yeah
ihr macht das alle freiwillig ne
gut dass ich hinter der Kamera stehe
[Musik]
bereit für den taste of the cake
ich mache jetzt eine der testlöffel hier
Buttercreme
Chips Marmelade
noch
schon so wie es im Verhältnis der Torte
ist weißt du
und die crumbles
ich weiß halt nie wie ich den essen soll
so so groß weiß so
einfach Mund weit auf Zack neu und so
[Musik]
sieht schon aus wie ein Kürbis
oder
fertig
ich habe jetzt überlegt die Oberfläche
das wird er so ein Kürbis der ungefähr
so aussieht vielleicht mache ich den
sogar so gruselig oder glatt ich weiß es
noch nicht jedenfalls hilft es mir
glaube ich wenn ich hier so ein paar
Sektionen einteile zum schneiden
nicht ganz gleichmäßig denn ein Kürbis
ist nicht gleichmäßig
ein Messer und kann hier so ein bisschen
einschneiden
ja
einfach die Einkerbungen erstmal und
schön die Kuchenreste auffangen die
brauchen wir noch
und aufpassen dass sie nicht die Anna
weg ist
vielleicht brauche ich den nämlich noch
[Musik]
für pinterest
ich rufe die Yvonne ja
Durchsage
spielt auch hier ab dann wisst Ihr wie
es bei ihr ankommt ja
Yvonne bitte in die studioküche Yvonne
bitte für ein paar behind the scenes
Yvonne bitte einmal in die studioküche
für behind the scenes Aufnahmen für
Pinterest Step by Step Fotos für die
Motivtorte
die neuen bitte in die studioküche
Yvonne bitte für ein paar behind the
season bitte einmal in die studienküche
für währenddessen auf meinem Profilbild
Weltmeister
[Gelächter]
alle Räume von der Murat bitte ins
Studio
ja also wenn natürlich schnell gegangen
wir werden zu dir gelaufen aber fürs
nächste Mal weiß ich selbst
ja also jetzt habe ich hier außen das
ganze eingeschnitten und jetzt einfach
versuchen mit Hilfe von den übrigen
Krümelchen hier der Messer der Palette
und der Rest Buttercreme einen schönen
kürbisbaum
hier oben rein schneiden und dann wird
das schon
ich liebe die Teigkarte da kannst du
einfach damit
da kannst du eine Rundung schneiden
okay und dann da oben natürlich da ist
ja so ein bisschen eingedrückt
da werde ich ihn auch ausfüllen
[Musik]
Gott bin ich heute kreativ
und dann nehme ich das ist echt aussieht
müssen da die Linien bis oben
durchgeführt werden
[Musik]
also mit der flexiblen Teigkarte kann
man tatsächlich diese Rundungen perfekt
machen ich mache jetzt erstmal eine
erste Schicht Buttercreme die dann so
diese ganzen Kuchenkrümel und so weiter
bindet dann kommt die Torte in
Kühlschrank und das ganze muss dann eben
noch mal fein ausgearbeitet werden also
da müsst ihr euch schon ein bisschen
mehr Mühe geben denn je genauer ihr
jetzt arbeitet unser cooler wird die
Torte später wenn von dann dann auch
drauf ist
und was auch wichtig ist dass es echt
aussieht das hier unten
eine Rundung rein geschnitten wird
[Musik]
okay also ich muss euch jetzt leider
hier alle im Raum enttäuschen denn die
Kuchenreste werde ich jetzt verbauen in
die Torte denn alles was ich unten und
am Rand weggeschnitten habe kommt hier
oben als 3D Modellage oben drauf und
wird mit Buttercreme ummantelt damit die
Torte zunehmend
3D geriert
[Musik]
seht ihr was das jetzt für ein Effekt
macht Torte drauf gesetzt Krümelchen
verwertet mit Buttercreme eingestrichen
und dann habt ihr so eine krasse 3D
Modellage und ich sage es euch meine
Lieben so was lernt ihr nur in der
maurerausbildung Maler und
lackiererausbildung erstes
Ausbildungsjahr darf ich das gelernt
sowas lernt man nicht in der Schule denn
meine bk-lehrerin hat damals gesagt wir
erinnern uns mit deinen modellierkünsten
kommst du nicht weiter als im
Kindergarten als Erzieherin das hat sie
zu mir gesagt
komplette Unterwasserwelt Spongebob
Schwammkopf habe ich modelliert
naja dafür Modelle ich heute einen
Kürbis aus Kuchen
ja ja
[Musik]
durch
los
[Musik]
wie findet ihr hallo
Toga
Murat
Yvonne
Caro Benedikt
y
Lena
Maurice
da haben sie mich gestern einfach
verlassen alle und einfach alle weg
feier ich Halloween halt alleine
also meine Torte
gehen heute ein bisschen arg geschminkt
ich weiß meine Torte Weizen über Nacht
im Kühlschrank
zum Halloween Make-up und zu den Haaren
gibt es übrigens auch ein eigenes Video
könnt ihr euch gerne anschauen denn ich
habe mich vorhin geschminkt da habe ich
gedacht wir können heute eine Halloween
Party feiern alle zusammen aber mal
gucken ob es noch zustande kommt
jedenfalls war die Torte über nach dem
Kühlschrank sie ist jetzt richtig schön
fest das habe ich hier noch einiges an
Buttercreme und die werde ich jetzt hier
verteilen um die Torte schön glatt zu
bekommen die muss jetzt nicht komplett
glatt sein denn es ist Halloween es kann
ruhig auch bisschen gruselig bleiben
aber ich möchte jetzt eine schöne
Grundlage für den Fondant machen ich
muss aber auch sagen wenn man hier jetzt
die ganzen Kuchenkrümel bedeckt und dann
wirklich schön glatt sieht könnte man
sehen tatsächlich auch ohne Fondant
belassen und könnt sagen da pudert man
so ein bisschen mit Farbe nach sieht
auch gut aus aber ich möchte doch eine
fondantschicht denn ich will noch ein
bisschen was drauf modellieren
ich muss sagen ich war früher nie so
halloweenmäßig unterwegs aber wenn dann
doch jemand eine Party steigen lässt
finde ich kann man sich da auch schon
ein bisschen schick machen
[Musik]
so gefällt mir der Kürbis ganz ganz gut
perfekt ich habe jetzt hier die Torte
fertig eingestrichen die muss jetzt
nicht perfekt glatt sein die kommt jetzt
erstmal einfach in den Kühlschrank damit
die Buttercreme fest wird und ich habe
jetzt hier noch einiges an Buttercreme
übrig ich habe noch mal eine komplette
Menge gemacht aber das ist gar nicht
schlimm denn die Torte hat genug und
die restbuttercremes für dich an
du kannst die Optik sauber machen und
ich knete
so jetzt ist er wieder sauber die Kamera
schön und ich habe hier noch zwei
fleißige Küchenhelfer einmal Ella sie
ist schon fertig ausgebildete Konditorin
und Model
genau marie ist es gerade dabei er macht
den ja Mediengestalter und jetzt macht
er bei Ella noch die Konditorausbildung
im Schnelldurchlauf ne okay Maurice darf
jetzt nämlich Fondant kneten ich muss
nämlich sagen dass ich beim Fondant
kneten ich kriege einfach mittlerweile
Krämpfe in den Fingern ich will jetzt
nicht beunruhigen so hart ist das Zeug
auch nicht
du darfst auch helfen hier ist noch ein
bisschen Kokosfett damit treibst du dir
schön die Hände ein und dann kannst du
so eins nach dem anderen einfach kneten
und ich mache so langsam so eine Rice
crispy Masse
ich habe hier schon Marshmallows
geschmolzen in der großen Schüssel da
kommt ein bisschen Butter rein
und dann Reis crispy
ne
so Bio Kokosöl
für Kuchen Haut und Haare
und Maurice hast du dir schon Motiv
ausgedacht
ja für dein Halloween Make-up was ich
dir gleich verpassen werde
ich hatte auch mal so eine Bomberjacke
damals soll ich aus wie ein Kürbis in
orange
okay Rice crispy Masse wer freut sich
auf die rice crispy-masse
ich habe deswegen auch ein bisschen mehr
gemacht denn für den kürbisstil brauche
ich nicht so viel aber da ich weiß dass
Ella den Riegel gerne ist mache ich ein
bisschen mehr
hier die Masse und drückt die einfach
und Form darauf einen
kürbisstil da oben ist ein Stiel
eigentlich nicht ne so dieses Zipfel da
oben
so
und aus dem Rest mache ich was für
Yasemin
schon krass ne Fondant kneten das ist
richtig Sport da richtig Bizeps Trizeps
hier
ich habe nicht mitgezählt
kannst viel mehr als nur Fondant kneten
ja da müssen wir das mal nachholen hier
was isst du denn am liebsten oder was
kennst du so aus deiner Kindheit Familie
Jugend
was dieser immer gern gebacken haben oh
ja Berliner sind auch lecker
ich habe eigentlich immer alles gegessen
als Kind
zubereitet haben eigentlich haben wir
immer beim Bäcker gekauft okay
vielleicht kann ich es das ja deswegen
finden wir was raus von packen wir das
zusammen
ja Ela bringst du den Maurice das Backen
bei Rot
es wird witzig
so das wird ein Mini Kürbis
zack
sehr gut ein Klumpen und den werde ich
jetzt gleich über die Torte stülpen also
ich wollte jetzt gleich aus ich mache
kurz meine Hände sauber vielen vielen
Dank Maurice vielen Dank ella
für eure tatkräftige Unterstützung
später gibt es Torte für alle da bin ich
dabei
[Musik]
tatsächlich gestern von dieser Torte
geträumt und habe geträumt wie ich sie
eindecke und dann ist mir nämlich so ein
Geistesblitz gekommen im Schlaf weil ich
ja auch will dass unten die Torte so
eingedeckt ist wie so ein 3d-kürbis
mache ich hier so ein kleines Stück
Rolle es aus aber ich wieder den Kürbis
gleich nicht auf den Kopf stellen dass
du keine Druckstellen bekommt
deswegen probiere ich mal was ich heute
geträumt habe also ich rolle einen
kleinen Kreis aus
der so groß ist wie die Fläche des
Kürbis ist
muss jetzt auch gar nicht so gut sein
dann hole ich die Torte
okay
jetzt Experiment los
jetzt mache ich die Ränder so ganz dünn
dann etwas backtrennspray zum Fixieren
jetzt hat sich da die Torte drauf
und jetzt
streiche ich das da hoch
und dünne ist so ein bisschen aus dass
man eigentlich quasi den Übergang gar
nicht sieht weil dann habe ich jetzt
schon mal den unteren Teil bedeckt und
kann später die Torte wie so einen
richtigen kürbisgut transportieren
ist einfach mit den Fingern nach oben
ausstreichen
[Musik]
nimm jetzt hier den Stil eines Pinsels
wobei ich könnte auch den Silikon
teilnehmen und kann jetzt hier diese
Mulden schön Nachfahren denn so dünn
sind meine Finger dann doch nicht und
hier ist jetzt einfach wichtig dass man
da gleich keinen Übergang sieht wobei
wenn man Übergang sehen wird mein Gott
das sind Kürbis der beschwert sich nicht
aber hier schön ausstreichen
und dann muss ich sagen freue mich schon
coole Sachen ne
ich muss schon sagen das klappt schon so
wie ich das hier habe wollte
weil ich möchte später
so ein kürbisschlitz rausholen wisst ihr
wie ich meine und dann ist er halt so
rund um eingedeckt
wie cool findet ihr es wenn ich den
jetzt aushöhle und innen was rein macht
statt Kürbiskernen die ihr im Kürbis
sind wo dann so sprinkles oder irgendwas
rausfahren ja
was sagst du Anna ja
dann doch so Halloween likes ein
bisschen bunten Zucker Mix oder
okay dann holen zuckermix weil bevor ich
nicht den bunten Zucker Mix habe
fröhliche gar nichts aus
oh mein Gott ist jetzt so cool aus es
wird so cool ich finde es sieht jetzt
schon cool aus so richtig geil aus sind
jetzt schon cool aus einfach
okay wir suchen mal kurz ein paar
zucker-sprinkles
[Musik]
okay wir nehmen jetzt grüne gelbe
orangene Süßigkeiten
die roten müssen leider gegessen werden
die rot mag ich gar nicht
die
Grünen ins Töpfchen die roten ins
Töpfchen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich fast vor lauter Fondant
und Süßigkeiten einfach vergessen das ja
auszuholen ich probiere jetzt was aus
mit dem Glas
ich steche jetzt einfach das Glas rein
und hoffe
dass die Füllung rauskommt
wenn ich schneide ich mit dem Messer
nach
[Musik]
ich weiß
hauptperfect hope perfect is this
ich habe gerade eine neue Technik
entwickelt wie man Torten aushält wieso
macht man vorher Tortenring ausstechen
entschuldigung aber
guck einfach
[Musik]
jetzt hier die ganzen Süßigkeiten rein
wisst ihr was auch cool gewesen wäre bei
einer größeren Öffnung
in Ananasschneider
[Musik]
nee also ich finde tatsächlich um jetzt
auch mal so alle anderen Videos von mir
so ein bisschen Revue passieren zu
lassen finde ich diese Technik einfach
gerade am coolsten weil am Anfang habe
ich dann mich sowas geplant habe mit
diesem überraschungsfach dann habe ich
die Böden in der Mitte ihnen schon
ausgehöhlt aber dann ist es viel
schwieriger die Torte zu stapeln und zu
füllen also sorry aber hey ich mache
glaube ich ein eigenes Video darüber
surprise surprise this is how you can
make a surprise cake
gut dann packe ich die Torte ganz kurz
den Kühlschrank ich hoffe meine Fondant
Decke ist noch nicht eingetrocknet
ausgetrocknet aber ich schreibe dir
einfach wieder weich
also
ich habe hier den Kürbis angeguckt und
ich habe mir den Kürbis angeguckt und
die haben oben keine runde Spitze die
muss das jetzt kurz abschneiden das
Zipfel hat
und ja morgen also muss ich die
wegschneiden
liebe Kinder ich muss einfach lachen mal
Spaß hab
Spaß am Backen
dann nehme ich mir etwas schwarzem
Fondant und da ist bereits etwas CMC
eingeknetet das und Pulver Cellulose
damit das Ganze aushärten kann
jetzt habe ich hier ich habe meine
fondantdecke einfach in die Silikonmatte
eingewickelt das Ding nicht austrocknet
es klebt jetzt zwar ein bisschen ohne
Silikonmatte aber
jetzt okay
[Musik]
ich glaube ich mache das jetzt so ich
spröder
wickelst dann ein ist eigentlich der
anders so nein andersrum so
okay die kurze Seite die dünne Seite
oben
dann wickle ich das hier so ein und
fertig
die Nähte so ein bisschen verstecken
und gut ist und dann machen wir noch so
ein bisschen Struktur rein mein
modelliermesser
[Musik]
gut dann wird jetzt der Kürbis
eingedeckt ein bisschen backtrennspray
damit davon dann haftet der ist ja ein
bisschen eingetrocknet aber nicht so
schlimm
drunter geht damit ich den Übergang
nicht sehe
dünner hier aus
[Musik]
langsam schön die Falten wegstreichen
und den Fondant unter der Torte so ein
bisschen wegschneiden und verstecken
[Musik]
es könnte hier zum Beispiel so ein
Modellierwerkzeug nehmen und die
Konturen perfekt nachzeichnen
das ist einfach so ein bisschen Tiefe
bekommen
wie so ein paar Risse sind oder kleine
ja wieso Blubberbläschen Warzen finde
ich das gar nicht schlimm denn das ist
so ein Kürbis der darf so aussehen wenn
ihr allerdings auch so eine Stelle habt
wie hier die bisschen unschön ist könnt
ihr jetzt ein bisschen Fondant nehmen
und mit Wasser zu einer Paste verrühren
einfach heißes Wasser rein
Werkzeug
[Musik]
auflösen und zerdrücken
dann könnt ihr das wirklich wie
Spachtelmasse einfach über die ja über
die unschönen Flecken geben und ein
bisschen verstreichen und dann trocknet
das Fest und dann ist es weg
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich dem Kürbis hier einfach
noch ein bisschen mehr Kontur und Tiefe
jetzt bekommt der Kürbis natürlich noch
seine schöne Optik ein Gesicht wobei ich
finde wenn man so ein stylischen
modernen eleganten Kürbis machen will
kann man den tatsächlich so lassen aber
ich habe jetzt hier mal ein Auge
aufgezeichnet was ich recht cool finde
ja das schneide ich jetzt hier zweimal
aus
und dann gibt es schwarze Augen und
einen schwarzen Mund man kriegt er auch
so nette so wie ich hier
okay die Augen kommen dahin da kommt der
Mund hier hin das heißt den markiere ich
jetzt einfach schon mal dann steht es
schon mal fest
ich halte das mal lieber
den ritze ich jetzt erstmal ein
[Musik]
für die Augen hier ein bisschen schwarz
ausrollen
[Musik]
gut jetzt habe ich die zwei Augen
ausgeschnitten die Schablone nehme ich
jetzt aber trotzdem für die Position
und platziere die so ein bisschen also
Augen sehen halt böse aus wenn sie so
ein bisschen nach unten gucken die
Augenbrauen so bei mir nein wenn sie
wenn sie so sind jetzt bisschen lieb aus
aber so macht und die Augenbrauen so
sind dann sieht es bisschen böse aus
deswegen machen wir das bisschen böse
[Musik]
ich gebe dir warte mal weißt du was ganz
wichtig ist beim Arbeiten immer Ordnung
zu machen Räume erstmal den ganzen Müll
weg
das aller aller Wichtigste
[Musik]
mein Kürbis bekommt jetzt noch
Augenbrauen damit gruselige aussieht aus
weißem Fondant da freue mich einfach so
eine kleine Wurst die vorne etwas dicker
hinten dünner ist die wird über das Auge
geklebt und dann habe ich hier noch ein
paar kleine schwarze fondantreste die
kommen in die Nase in den Mund und den
Rest werde ich einfach mit flüssiger
Lebensmittelfarbe so ein bisschen
auspinseln und hier außen damit die
Schatten und die Vertiefungen noch mal
so richtig hervorgehoben werden mit
Pulverfarbe aus Pulver mit einem
trockenen Pinsel aber jetzt machen wir
mal eins nach dem anderen
[Musik]
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott
er lag darf ich mal kurz herzlichen
Glückwunsch ich glaube du bist die
jüngste meisterkonditorin der Welt und
danach kommt glaube ich direkt eine
große Schwester oh mein Gott die müssen
wir später dazu stellen darf ich die
später mit bei mir ins Bild stellen und
ja
cool auch ständig dahinter kann die
bisschen trocknen
[Musik]
und jetzt nehmt ihr die Pulverfarbe und
arbeitet damit schön die Schatten aus
Sally Murat sag mal kurz ich finde auch
allen
[Musik]
dein Ernst jetzt
dass ich aus wie Selma Hayek von dusk
till dawn ist doch ein nightmare before
Christmas das sieht so ein bisschen
ähnlich aus und weißer Kürbis ja ich
hoffe es ist kein Kürbiskuchen drin nein
ehrlich jetzt
Gott sei Dank
vorhin war tatsächlich der Dennis kurz
da und hat gesagt
das ist gut schmeckt aber trotzdem
cool
und gleich könnt ihr euch dann bereit
machen die Kids die sollen sich schon
mal was anziehen denn gleich startet
unsere family Halloween Party ja okay
wir probieren damit
ich bin gleich fertig nur noch
ausstattieren Stiel drauf zack fertig
[Musik]
ich glaube mein Kürbis ist fertig
ich hoffe euch gefällt euch und was ich
jetzt richtig cool fand
wenn ihr einen Namen für diese Torte
findet also schreibt doch mal gerne ich
hatte ja mal Karl den Kürbis ich halte
Walter watermelon und jetzt fehlt noch
einen Namen für dieses Semester weg
natürlich
mein Gott du bist so süß ich will dich
gar nicht anschneiden aber wir werden
uns gleich tun
[Musik]
seid ihr bereit für den Anschnitt ja was
hast du eigentlich für eine
crazy-familie ja ich weiß ich bin der
einzig normale in der Familie kann das
sein
lustig aus
zum Vampir
cool wie finden sie Torte richtig cool
ist echt hammermäßig aus ich glaube auf
jeder
hast du die gemacht nein oder doch die
Ella ganz allein
ich bin froh dass die Kinder alles von
dir haben
auch viel von dir Humor Intelligenz
[Musik]
ist lustig Ehrgeiz ja
also okay ich wollte eigentlich noch auf
Samira warten ach Samira kommt gerade
wir warten mit dem Anteil auf Samira
okay
ja ich hoffe
sowas nicht anna ist auch nicht
verkleidet ich wollte Anna auch
schminken und die restliche Firma die
freuen sich jetzt aber alle auf Torte
okay man kann aber auch fairerweise mal
echt dazu sagen wir haben gerade 19:30
Uhr der Dreck ging länger denn morgen
sind wir nicht da und die Torte musste
halt fertig werden und dann seit 19:30
Uhr und außer uns ist halt dann keiner
mehr da ne Eileen noch im Büro Anna
hinter der Kamera unser Papa ist mein
Papa mich so na toll
[Musik]
jetzt wird die Torte angeschnitten seid
ihr bereit ja
ist ein Crunch drin
wow ich glaube ich muss einfach noch
zwei drei Stücke anschneiden und dann
kommen die Hetis daraus aber egal jetzt
machen wir gleich im Anschluss ich
glaube jetzt wollen erstmal alle einfach
probieren
wollt ihr noch ein bisschen Blut
ist es echt das Blut
wir machen das einfach so
gerade
ich glaube der Papa denkt sich gerade so
warum
wer möchte probieren
schmecken mögen deine Hände niemals
Unheil sehen
und was für ein Papagei lecker
nicht so zaghaft Murat komm gehen wir
Oma auch eine Gabe
und auch nicht zu süß finde ich cool
schmeckt dir die Torte ist echt cool
ich habe eine Kürbismarmelade gemacht
und die rein gefüllt mit Quitten und die
Quitten habe ich mit Papa gesammelt
cool
also ich schneide jetzt gleich noch mal
die Torte an dass ihr den Effekt gleich
sehen könnt denn ich habe ehrlicherweise
nicht ganz bis zur Mitte geschnitten
weil der Strunk da ist alles gut wir
gehen jetzt gleich noch Abendessen bei
uns drüben ich hoffe euch hat dieses
Video gefallen und vergesst nicht und
das Video zu kommentieren wie dieser
Kürbis heißen könnte also Karl der
Kürbis geht nicht dann gibt's schon
jetzt könnt ihr euch gerne einen anderen
Namen aussuchen und ich hoffe dass ihr
ganz viel Spaß haben werdet auf eure
Halloween Feier mit euren Halloween
Süßigkeiten das Rezept gibt's wie immer
in meiner App und auf meinem Blog bis
zum nächsten Mal macht's gut
was wäre es wenn einfach Kürbis Kürbis
oder Kirby
Kürbis oh mein Gott
Ella du bist echt okay komm jetzt komm
jetzt beiß einmal rein in deinen Kürbis
essen
wir gehen jetzt alle essen und dann
noch
was gehen wir essen
der Papa schmeckt richtig gut gell aber
ihr fragt doch immer wer bei uns die
ganzen Kuchen und Torten ist
anfangs war es nur der Murat aber jetzt
eigentlich schon immer das ganze Team es
gibt Kuchen
oh mein Gott
ja ja Moment
größer
du bist doch schon der größte
noch Blut
bitte ich komm ich habe hier was für
dich dein Kuchen
Gott oh danke danke schön Gott hier ist
wieder eine Sauerei
mach mal kurz sauber
[Musik]